تواصل قوه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي حصار بلدتي
حواره وقرى مجاوره جنوبيه نابلس لليوم
السادس على التوالي بزعم محاوله الوصول
الى منافذ الهجوم المسلح الذي ادى الى
مقتل مستوطنين الاحد الماضي وابلغت قوه
الاحتلال الاهالي بتمديد اغلاق المرافق
والمحال التجاريه حتى يوم الاحد القادم
ومن المقرر اي ينظم ممثل دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
ودبلوماسيون رفيع المستوى لنحو 20 دوله
ومؤسسات حقوقيه بينها اسرائيليه جوله
ميدانيه اليوم في حواره وقريه زعتره جنوبي
نابلس للوقوف على ما خلفته اعتداءات
المستوطنين على الفلسطينيين وممتلكاتهم
معنى الان من قريه زعتره جنوب نابلس مراسل
الجزيره سمير ابو شماله سمير كيف يبدو
الوضع وايضا كيف تستعد زعتر ومناطق اخرى
لاستقبال هذه الوفود
يعني يمكن القول بانه نحن في انتظار
الدقائق القليله المقبله لوصول الوفد الذي
يمثل دول الاتحاد الاوروبي وايضا سفراء
ودبلوماسيين دوليين اضافه الى ممثلين على
المؤسسات حقوقيه ومنها اسرائيليه
لتنظيم جوله ميدانيه في قريه زعتره حيث
نقف الان وهذه القريبه من حاجز زعتره
العسكري الذي شهد قبل في يوم الاحد الماضي
استشهاد الشاب سامح الاقطش الجوله هذه
الجوله التي ستنظم في هذه القريه وهي اولى
محطات هذه الجوله
سيكون هناك اطلاع عن قرب من قبل الممثلين
الاتحاد الاوروبي والدوليين والاستماع الى
شهادات السكان في هذه القريه الصغيره التي
يقطن فيها 17 عائله من ابناء العمومه من
عائله الابطش وقد استشهد في هذا المكان
تحديدا الشاب سامح اقطش الذي كان يحاول
التصدي اضافه الى
مئات من المواطنين
للمجموعات المستوطنين الذين جاؤوا الى هذا
المكان وذلك للاعتداء عليهم وحرقه
ممتلكاتهم تم اطلاق النار عليهم من قبل
المستوطنين مما ادى الى استشهاده والذي
كان هو بالاساس قد عاد من الاراضي التركيه
وذلك لتقديم حيث تطوع هناك وقدم بعض
المعونات الانسانيه والمساعدات
لضحايا المنكوبين لفي زلزال تركيا وقد مكث
هناك اربعه ايام وهو قد عاد من تركيا قبل
نحو اسبوع وتم اطلاق النار عليه واستشهد
في مكان عمله عندما كان يتصدى للمستوطنين
وجيش الاحتلال الذي كان برقه المستوطنين
عندما حاولوا الاعتداء على هذه القريه في
داخل بلده حواره وهي الملاصقه تماما الى
هذا هذه القريه
هناك اغلاق للمحل التجاريه ما زال لليوم
السادس على التوالي وذلك باوامر عسكريه من
قبل الجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وبذلك لعدم
وجود احتكاك بين الفلسطينيين والمستوطنين
الذين يسلكون هذا الشارع تحديدا الذي يربط
بين حاجز زعتره العسكري وايضا الحجز حوار
ويمر من داخل البلده وهذا يمثل احتكاك
مباشر بين الفلسطينيين والمستوطنين وايضا
يؤمنون حركه وتنقل المستوطنين بشكل مستمر
وعلى مدار الساعه ولكن يحلمون الفلسطينيين
من حياتهم الاقتصاديه والتجاريه والحياتيه
المعيشيه اليوميه من خلال الاستمرار في
اغلاق هذه المحل التجاريه وايضا تعطيل كل
المرافق الحياتيه للفلسطنين في هذه البلده
اليوم السادس على التوالي لكن هناك
معلومات تفيد بان اليوم الساعه السادسه
بالتوقيت المحلي سيتم السماح للفلسطنين
بفتح محلهم التجاريه وذلك بعد ان يدخل
اليهود واي المستوط يوم السبت المقدس
لديهم عند مغيب الشمس وبذلك يتيح
للفلسطينيين التحرك في هذا المكان وفتح
المحل التجاريه كل هذه الاجراءات وهذه
الاجراءات العسكريه ايضا تتزامن مع
الاعلان عن استشهاد الفتى محمد سليم في
بلده عزون يوم امس شرق قلقيليه برصاص
الجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خلال مواجهات
اندلعت في البلده مساء يوم امس من قريه
زعتره جنوب نابلس مراسله الجزيره سميره
ابو شماله شكرا جزيلا لك